foreign
[Music]
I'm butter I'm going to be your host
today for this talk we have a 45 minutes
together to talk about a lot of fun
stuff I'm going to be covering a lot of
things around credential stuffing
account fraud payment fraud Bots
phishing malware whatever you name it so
hopefully it's going to be enjoyable I'm
going to live on purpose a lot of time
for Q a as well for folks to come and
ask your questions but this is supposed
to be a fun session so hopefully you'll
enjoy it before we get started
um I'm butter I'm the product manager
for two products recaptcha Enterprise
and web risk I've been at Google for
actually about eight and a half years at
this stage spent a lot of my careers
actually fighting a lot of you know bad
stuff that people do on the internet and
I started my career at Google protecting
search users against everything that's
bad links that's how I kind of fell in
love with the team called safe browsing
that protects the world against fishing
malware social engineering links I I
joined the team to help actually fight
all of this across Google services from
Gmail ads
Etc and then more recently I joined
actually the recapture and webris teams
to make sure that actually we can bring
a lot of what we've done to make Google
better at protecting itself against
account takeovers and fraud and Bots to
in the hands of our customers right so
it's a bit of my background and so feel
free to actually ask questions and
stories in the Q a at the end
today we're going to actually cover a
few things one is what kind of
reestablished basis on where recapture
Enterprise is at today what it is I know
a lot of you think that is either
squiggly letters or challenges but it's
a lot more than that and then we will be
covering also ATO and fake accounts
everything that has to do with leaked
credentials phishing credential theft
Etc how can recapture Enterprise help
there and also we'll be covering
everything around payment fraud so
chargebacks Etc like how actually it's
being used out there in the Wild by some
of our customers to protect their users
and then we'll do through a demo where
we'll actually demonstrate how you as a
developer or a business owner you can
leverage our solution to protect
yourself and your users
um
great so
quick you know level setting recapture
is now frictionless it's been
frictionless since 2018.
you know since 2017 a lot of people
think of us as a squiggly letters then
the Beloved by the internet challenge as
well that everybody probably has solved
at least a few times in their lifetimes
um since actually 2018 we launched an
invisible version and I think it's the
first time that we kind of announced
that on stage but more like the majority
of our traffic today runs on our
invisible version of recaptcha so we
made a lot of strides there to make sure
that businesses and every of every sizes
from small mom and pop shops all the way
through some of the largest companies
out there can protect themselves Without
Really blocking users with these
challenges
um and what we're seeing here really is
a few things one this was our bet to
make sure that in the future without
challenge we actually have a robust way
to protect users and applications but
also it's a real Testament that this is
something that developers needed out
there so really here having you know
majority of our traffic over 50 run
through that invisible version is a
clear statement of hopefully something
that you may have noticed is that you
solve less and less of these challenges
today so you can thank all the
developers that have adopted this and if
you haven't already give it a try
in 2020 we've actually evolved the
product to be recapture Enterprise so
recapture Enterprise is basically think
of it of the the Enterprise version that
can scale with your business it's part
of Google Cloud security so it's a gcp
product you accept new terms when you
sign up with recaptcha Enterprise which
are the gcp terms we provide slas slos
and a lot more new features that can
allow you to protect yourselves against
different use cases that we'll be
covering and deep diving on today
right another strength of this is that
obviously a lot of people are actually
trusting recapture and it's there is a
reason why you actually have encountered
it at least once in your lifetime is
that it's because it's on over 6 million
sites today and growing so when I
started actually on this role over a
couple years ago in genre capture we
were about four million sites and this
has been growing at quite a rapid rate
just because a lot of people from every
sizes of every business size believes
and trusts in this in this and we're
really committed to keeping it being a
really important part of the
infrastructure of the internet to
actually protect against bots and all
other types of Road
but really the the thing that happened
about three years ago when we launched
recapture Enterprise came from the fact
that a lot of us actually sat down and
thought we have all of these sites that
trust us we have all of these use cases
that there that they're actually
protecting themselves against using
recaptcha but what are the use cases
where we could actually make a dent and
help these businesses build around and
really what came out is a few things one
is we needed to make sure that we
protect account protections everything
around protections and account fraud
think credential stuffing true Factor
authentication password Leak Detection
fake accounts phishing Etc so everything
that has to do with an account loss or a
fake account created on an application
and that's used by using bots in essence
we were a bot management solution three
years ago today we're a full front
solution where you can rely on us for
things that are Beyond Bots
the Second Use case and all of this
comes from the data and how people were
using us is payments fraud payments
fraud has you know a lot of issues
around chargebacks erroneous rejections
of real users trying to check out and
this relies on a lot of data and
visibility which luckily we have with
our six million websites that we protect
but also with all the teams internally
at Google that are building risk models
that we've partnered with to bring that
in the hands of customers and later
actually we'll be looking at how this is
being used in the real world by some of
our customers to protect themselves
against everything around chargebacks
and payment fraud
scraping use case obviously for a lot of
e-commerce sites this is actually vital
for a lot of traveling travel platforms
this is important because that allows
some competitors to do scalping or
cutting them so we're also providing a
lot of protection there and really the
philosophy behind this when we launched
recapture Enterprise was two things
around these three use case Three core
use cases one you should be able to run
us on all devices that your users use to
access your application what that means
is we are able to actually be embedded
in a WAFF so that you can actually block
the traffic you know at the first layer
over the wire this is great for
streaming platforms I still rely on
setup Boxes
Etc
two is to make sure that we provide you
as good an experience for your users and
protection both on your native apps that
you develop as well as the web the web
is what we've been doing really well for
15 years what we've brought here is um
actually things like you know native
sdks that you can embed in IOS and
Android there are dynamically updated so
you don't have to update your app every
time we update recaptcha and so really
this is a there's been this has been a
push we've done and we'll see later some
of the launches that we've made that are
actually going in that direction like
for example our integration our native
integration into Cloud armor
on the other end we also understand that
developers rely on multi-cloud
multi-platform Etc so you can actually
take recapture and you put you can
deploy it wherever you are it doesn't if
you're a gcp customer obviously you have
some gains from the fact that it's
natively implemented vidcp but if you're
an AWS customers if you're running your
own backend if you're running your apps
anywhere you should be able to deploy
recaptcha so that you know you you can
rely on that infrastructure that you've
already built so that we don't come in
your way and try to force you into some
pieces of infrastructure that you're not
using today so that's kind of the
philosophy and core tenets around really
being a developer-centric platform and
that around these three use cases and
more right
now some of the things we've done in the
past three years that you may have seen
is actually launching a few more
products and features that will allow
you to actually protect your sites
against these use cases first thing we
did is actually recapture Enterprise in
essence is a fairly young product even
though you know looking at the market
and the adoption of the product is
starting to become more and more
ubiquitous in taking its space we're
here in March 2020 we launched recap
science into ga
so ja stands for General availability
meaning that anyone can actually come
and grab the product
second thing we did was our Cloud armor
integration let native integration
actually allows you to deploy it to
deploy that get the score from a
captioner price or a risk score for
distributed human or robot and over the
wire following all your rules be able to
actually remove some of the kind of easy
bot traffic so they don't even hit your
application right
um
other thing we did is we capture
password Leak Detection we'll cover more
in details what it is but really this
allows you to detect if a user logging
in onto your platform is using leaks
credentials and leaks and that database
is a partnership that we've done with
the password checkup team at Google it's
a similar database as per that's helping
you protect your accounts on Chrome
today so you receive an alert telling
you to change your passwords we're using
very similar database in order to power
this product
the native mobile SDK is both for
Android and iOS in November 2022 we
launched that allow you to protect your
native apps as well as your pro you can
protect the web your web application
recapture account Defender GA was a big
parading shift in the way we're actually
protecting accounts as opposed to trying
to answer the question is this a bot or
human this is actually trying to answer
the question is this the right person
coming back is this a fake account
should I 2fa this user can I let them
through can I save can I save SMS money
by not authenticating this user Etc
and then finally and the one that I'm
personally like very proud of and like
really excited about is everything wrong
recapture fraud prevention that we did
earlier this year that actually allows
businesses business businesses to
protect themselves against chargeback
and other types of Fraud and we're going
to do a really nice Deep dive into what
that looks like for you as a developer
what type of scores we give you and how
that's integrated with other parts of
the ecosystem that Google offers
so right now we'll zoom on account fraud
this is actually the largest use case
that our customers sign up for because
this is really our strength and what
we've been doing best for the past 15
years
it's really kind of to go back and level
set sort of make sure everybody's on the
same page the ATO problem unfortunately
relies on a very simple problem is the
fact that people reuse their passwords
it's it sounds crazy that in 2023 2023
we still have this problem but literally
if you think about it how often are you
actually prompted when you install a new
application with you creating a new
password for a new account that you now
have to manage on your application and
that problem makes it that if this data
leaks somewhere so one of the
application the 100 applications that I
use on my phone
has a data leak that makes any other
application vulnerable for an account
takeover for that specific account right
another thing is more and more services
especially since kovid have moved online
more and these accounts are becoming
more and more important today you can do
your taxes online you can buy food you
can get your groceries you can monitor
how your kids are doing at daycare you
can you know manage your bank account
Etc which makes actually now to date the
account of a user a really strong asset
for a customer right or for an attacker
to get their hands on it so very
important and obviously scaling bot
attacks is cheaper than ever you know
infrastructure costs are coming down
but as a service is a thing you can
actually ask people to run them for you
as long as you get your hands on the
database of leak credentials they can do
it on your behalf
another thing is attackers really rely
on a few things in order to be able to
do these account takeovers number one as
we said stolen credentials stolen
credential pairs meaning users and
passwords they need bots in automation
or click Farms so clickfiring is being
humans actually doing uh the attack
right that is becoming more and more
prevalent and parts of the world
especially as accounts have become more
and more valuable so for example think
of a crypto exchange if I get my hands
on your crypto there is no way to claim
those back but those accounts are very
can are like very um attractive to
attackers for example and that means
that actually it's cheaper to even pay a
human to do this attack as opposed to a
bot given that the reward at the end is
really high
everything that they need is also
similarly to you as business owners they
need the network they need devices they
need infrastructure and that's a very
important point because we protect 6
million websites so we've had instances
where customers actually deploy
recaptcha and so their traffic of bots
drop because if we fingerprint one bot
it's actually it propagating to the Six
Million sites we protect so that's kind
of a deterrent already just having it
there on the page and then obviously
anything around stolen or hijacked phone
numbers and emails for MFA for example
or being able to bypass two-factor
authentication in the worst cases we've
seen with financial institutions
sometimes the attackers are even on the
phone with the victim unfortunate
so here we actually what we'll do is
that we'll really walk through this the
all these things that we've just
discussed and give you really
um an overview of how we're thinking
about the problem and why we've brought
some of these Solutions and features to
Market
the first solution that we've built
which is I think one of the most
important we've built because that's one
of the easiest way for any business
owner to make sure that the password
hygiene of their customers is clean this
password link detection password Leak
Detection allows you in line at the
moment of login sign up password reset
to check against our database whether
the user is using leaks credentials
based on our database of billions of
entries that we either purchase from
vendors that we Harvest ourselves that
we've done that we had collaborating
with Google and it's actually constantly
updated to make sure that you know you
can keep your users safe
this has no fancy ML and AI yet it's
literally a kind of Boolean answer on is
this person at risk of getting hijacked
because they're using stolen credentials
and if yes
prompt them to change their password
it's the easiest thing you can do to
protect accounts even before you get
into the fancy machine learning and AI
you can do over this problem
so and that's the great thing about this
is that it's directly integrated in
recapture Enterprise so when you ask for
an assessment from recaptcha meaning
when you ask recapture hey do you think
this is a bot or human at the same time
you can ask for captcha hey is the are
these credentials clean based on your
database
another strength of this product is that
we've taken a different approach than
the competition we're not providing you
an answer on whether this password is
risky because we've seen it across
multiple
databases we're answering the question
of are is this credential pair leaked
somewhere on the web which is very
unique to the user meaning that you can
with confidence tell the user you are at
risk because I know that your account
has been linked somewhere all of this is
done in the privacy
preserving manner we're providing
blinders in a way that we are not able
to see these credentials in plain text
what should what we do is that we return
the hash prefix matches and then you can
map that to that user right so this is
great for everyone as like in government
for example or like want to protect
their constituents without giving away
some data that allows you to do that in
a privacy preserving manner where Google
has no way to know what these
credentials are it's a one-way
encryption method
second is of course the credential
Staffing attack starts what you need for
the credential stuffing attack is Bots
or humans but in this case what we've
done is you know you've got your
recapture Enterprise score between zero
and one zero being a bot one being a
human in increments of 0.1 so you have
11 scores that you can use in order to
actually act against the bot attack or
think of a challenge you can throw them
or think of an MFA you can present them
so at this stage of the attack actually
what you're able to do with one API call
return to your under 100 milliseconds in
a Json format meaning you're the only
person that sees that as a response the
attacker has no idea about what you're
getting back we're able to answer the
question are these credentials clean are
they actually vulnerable at being
attacked
and is the support or human trying to
perpetrate the attack now in the old
world of Bot management we'll probably
just tell you I think this is a bot on
my login page or my login action
therefore I think this is
a credential Staffing attack
what we've done is that actually we went
a step further and we launched the
account Defender account Defender also
lives on top of recaptcha with the same
account requests the same request
assessment you'll get an extra signal
that will answer the question is this
batter coming back to his account or is
this someone trying to log in on his
behalf right and what we do is that we
return you a label that will say
is this suspicious login activity is
this for example for an account creation
is this a suspicious account creation
but really all of this is powered by
what we call the profile matching engine
and that profile matching is looking at
hundreds of signals for that user every
time they log in to make sure that when
one day there is a deviation in their
normal behavior we can use as a business
owner or developer alert you that
something fish is going on make sure you
do a fail this user and that's a padding
shift because in the attack where the
credentials are clean and it is a human
it doesn't mean that it's better coming
back trying to log in on his Gmail
account and that's really like The
Parting shift that we've done with
account Defender
and of course then we offer recaptcha
MFA which allows you to Twitter your
user by sending an oh no TP via email we
also have on our roadmap to allow folks
to bring their own SMS provider in order
to trigger natively with the recaptcha
score and SMS verification and all of
which is also protected by your SMS
fraud solution that we recently launched
in private preview so you can save on
those SMS dollars because we know this
year it's been painful for Developers
then of course everything you can do in
order to reduce this password friction
in MFA is account Defender helps you
actually with
um that profile match and a risk engine
it allows you to actually save on SMS
dollars in this case or for example
avoid that friction of always asking a
user to MFA to pass their OTP Etc
depending on the business financial
institutions actually appreciate that
friction they don't mind it I think you
know when you have more inpatient users
that are using your platforms it might
be actually frustrating to have to
either pass a recapture challenge or MFA
so this is a good way for you to
actually build that profile over time of
the user and allow them to bypass a lot
of the MFA friction
another thing that's really important is
another way to lose your credentials is
phishing right this has been there since
the internet has been around but really
what we do here is if you've ever heard
of safe browsing which protects 5
billion devices around the world it's
been doing it for 17 years it's embedded
in most browsers and we showed big red
interstitial to users in those browsers
and devices that allows you to submit to
us any phishing page that you know is
targeting your brand or your business so
that we can block it in these five
billion devices so here actually at that
stage of the attack
again you're able to say is are these
credentials leaked on the dark web
somewhere is this a bot or human
is this actually an account takeover
risk or not should I 2fa this person
trigger the 2fa
submit the phishing pages to recapture
through web risk and safe browsing for
protection phishing protection
and make sure that you actually don't
add friction for your profile matches
and your real users are coming back
if you think about three years ago the
only question you could have been you
would have been able to answer is is
this a bot or a human which only gives
you part of the story and this is really
where we're going with this and most of
this is available both on mobile on web
and through our web Integrations
and finally of course like one thing we
wanted to mention is we recently
released in private preview an SMS fraud
solution so toll fraud has been a sore
point for developers this year we
actually pivoted part of our roadmap
because of that there hasn't been I
think a single month where I talked to
our customers where SMS fraud and told
fraud has been brought up as an issue
and we've recently released the score
actually that you can use in order to
reduce SMS fraud where we will give you
a likeliness for an SMS to be SMS fraud
so you can block it before you send it
to the user right now the model is that
when that SMS is gone from uh to for the
verification you have to pay for it what
recaptcha can do here similar to payment
fraud is that you can block it up front
so you can save on those SMS dollars and
we know that in some regions of the
world this SMS prices have skyrocketed
to 90 cents an SMS for verification
which can be very expensive
Second Use case is really everything
around bulk config account creation
similarly here recaption Enterprise
allows you to say is this a bot or human
trying to create a an account very easy
way for you to feel to Rack bulk fake
account creation Now assuming these are
humans what account Defender does is
that on top of this it gives you a
signal that will tell you suspicious
account creation
that is trained based on you know the
millions and billions of interactions we
see coming through our platform and
we've built models that allow us to
recognize when a fake account creation
is in is happening because of for
example a bot or a human or a click Farm
Etc what's great about this is that this
is a an API response again so the
attacker doesn't know that you're on to
them at that stage meaning that you can
earmark that account and maybe limit
some functionalities on your website
until you verify that they're a genuine
user
fake accounts are a big issue especially
for companies that are growing at a fast
pace you know when you need to report to
your investors your actual growth
numbers that's an issue if these are
actually biased by bots so really what
we're doing here is trying to give you
all these tools to be able to clean up
those those Bots that created the
accounts on your platform
but the most important piece here is the
related accounts API once you've
identified that bad seed usually if you
don't have a large company you don't
necessarily have a fraud or trust and
safety team that can go and investigate
each and every account and go and take
it down
what the related accounts API allows you
to do is actually to speed up that
process so it's almost if you had a
fraud team that went and investigated
for that specific account all the other
accounts that belong to the same
attacker why this is important because
we're doing a lot of clustering and ML
and AI in the background to do this
clustering right so it's an unsupervised
learning model that based on all the
signals that we collect based on network
devices and behavior on the page we're
able to tell you like hey you know like
this account that you just gave me there
is about 150 other accounts that pertain
to the same attacker therefore if you
want to take it down you can take it
down if you want to disable them Etc you
can with the related accounts API so
very powerful tool to save you time and
money on the investigation and
enforcement
and here again you know you with a SMS
fraud that's a great way for you to
block these accounts so that you have
less of these fake accounts that creates
that SMS fraud problem for you
all right zoom on payment fraud
and
really
um this year has been for us it's been a
really a turning point when we launched
this in May of 2023.
um we've launched this uh this new uh
product called fraud prevention and what
prev fraud prevention does is really
protect that payment page so for the
past 10-15 minutes we've actually we
went on through the case of what we're
doing to help you create and protect
that account that's your first step into
making sure that fraud is not as rampant
on your on your website the reason for
that is over 75 80 of fraud starts
either from an ATO or a fake account
and the rest is probably you know you
can attribute it to Friendly fraud Etc
what we've done here is how can we
actually provide a solution that
combines the power of recaptcha is
visibility over 6 million sites and the
signals that we collect there
with other parts of Google so that we
can actually provide a full fraud
solution for your payments in order to
actually solve a few things one is
everything around chargebacks which can
cost a lot of money to businesses and
then on the other end how can we help
you improve your erroneous rejection
rate meaning you know how do we avoid
that you have to actually reject the
user when you've spent all these
marketing dollars and at The Last Mile
when they're on your payment page you
reject them because you know you have a
solution that maybe is over conservative
on that fraud problem
so read that's what we've done and then
you know everything's powered by the
same people that build recapture the
account protection Suite that we just
built and really is like protecting over
six million sites and one trillion
transactions
and here what we've done is a lot of
things you know have come together over
the years over the past three years what
we've done is not just build this
product we build these Partnerships
within Google so that we can leverage
each other's fraud intelligence to make
to put it in the hands of our customers
to be able to protect themselves as well
as we protect ourselves that all starts
with recaptcha because recaptcha is
already present on your page it's
already protecting your page but on top
of that we've Pro we've partnered with
teams like Google payments team that
helps us build those risk models we're
partnering with safe browsing to help
you protect yourselves again you know
phishing malware social engineering that
can lead to credential theft for example
and of course above all of this once
actually this is all deployed on your
page it allows us to build those
tailored models and custom models on
your page and on your for your business
based on the annotations we receive from
you to data we see on your end and so
that we can have not just the one out of
the box model that works for everyone
but actually custom models that work for
you
and right here what we've done is if you
think about the way it normally works
either on one hand one of your vendor
will have a large visibility on
everything
instrument right so they will be able to
tell you you know based on my
intelligence and my network of users I
know that this credit card is bad I know
that this debit card is bad
unfortunately this is just part of the
story the real story here is who that
person is is this an account takeover is
this a hijacked is it a fake account is
what Behavior have I seen from this user
in the past on my website
and what is the reputation of this user
over the Six Million sites when it
interacts with them
and really when you think about it
recaptcha brings that perspective
Google pay and those teams help us I
should bring that on our end and when we
build those risk models together it
gives you a powerful signal to use in
order to reject or accept a transaction
on your site or accept or reject a
certain user on your site
and here there is a lot more data that
you know we've built in terms of like
inputs we have Merchants data payment
processors blogs and websites
marketplaces all of that fits into our
models so that we can build more more
and better models across those six
million sites
and so now actually the way we've
structured this again if you think about
the way we were thinking about
approaching
um the release of recaptch Enterprise
it's a developer-centric platform
meaning that we want to put in your
hands the tools that you need the scores
that you need and maybe blend them with
your own fraud engine other solutions
that you're using in vendors
so what we do is that we return you a
few scores number one transaction risk
the probability of the transaction
should be fraudulent this is you know
what you want to use in order to
actually add on top of your own
intelligence whether you should reject
this transaction or not
but we're not stopping there what we
want is to make sure that you know what
are some of the other signals we provide
or we we had in order to make that
decision the first one is what's the
likeliness of this instrument to be
stolen that's all the intelligence we
have built and gathered from working
with other risk teams that have helped
us build those models so here you'll be
able to say well you know what there is
100 chance that this is a bad instrument
I should probably reject this
transaction
two is what's the likeliness of this
card testing being car testing meaning
are these Bots or humans trying to wash
a certain number of credit cards that
they bought on the dark web for example
to see if they are valid on this website
so we're giving you a score for that and
one of the most important thing is the
behavioral trust verdict what that
allows you to do is to make sure that
you can retain all of these users that
you've spent marketing dollars bringing
to your platform coming at the checkout
page and be able to actually reduce that
erroneous rejection rate and that's
actually based on you know a lot of data
that we see on for that user across
those websites have they actually
checked out have they been actually a
fraudulent user in another platform etc
etc and this is great because this is
actual dollars that you've saved and
that's an actual customer acquisition
cost that you can bring down as opposed
to attribute to you know your fraud
solution being too conservative
we actually have a great use case that
we've shared recently unfortunately we
can't have the customer on stage talk
about it but GoFundMe is actually using
empowered by recaptcha fraud prevention
today and what the way they're doing it
is that they're checking whether a
specific solution or a specific
transaction on the page is fraudulent
and you know that unlocks millions of
dollars in additional funds with secure
transactions that's frictionless and
user experience meaning that if you've
donated recently in any GoFundMe
campaign for example for the Maui fires
and so on all of that was actually in
the background protected by recaption
and price fraud prevention
there is an informal machine learning
models with recapture responses and they
mitigate attacks in real time meaning
that everything we've described happens
in real time at the moment the user
clicks on pay check out login register
under 100 milliseconds and that's a very
powerful tool that you can add on top of
your your solution
and really on their in their own words
in in Matthew's own words recapture
prevent Enterprise fraud prevention is
fantastic at targeting bad payments and
mitigating them in real time while at
the same time allowing payments to go
through with minimum friction in the
case of
of GoFundMe this means that you know
causes actually receive the dollars that
would have otherwise been you know in
the hands of attackers and fraudsters so
that's one of our favorite customers we
had to we deployed this with and we're
happy to actually yield a great results
with
great we have about 15 minutes left
we'll do a quick demo so I can show you
what this looks like in
what how you can consume those scores
how you how they look like in terms of
response and maybe look at different use
cases for example if a user has logged
in or if a user is trying to check out
so that you can actually see what that
will look like for you as a business
I'm just gonna log in here
hope I don't type my password in front
of everyone in plain text
all right
yeah
okay all right so going back to like the
presentation the early presentation we
mentioned really today recaptcha is
invisible so for you in the room who had
never used recaptcha invisible the way
it works is that you get a score back so
when a user tries to log in
but
and they click on sign in
you'll be able to actually get a
response that will tell you whether it
is user when trying to log in are they
both origin oh sorry I think we have
of course the demo gods are not happy
because the internet is not working
in a second
all right
I'm just gonna reload this real quick
it's always when you need the demo that
it doesn't work
um makes it seem more real exactly yeah
at least you know now that it's not
staged
uh great I think we're back on all right
so the Enterprise page there you go so
let's assume that a user tries to log in
here
and when they click login
what you get here is
with a simple implementation of
recaptcha obviously it's under your
token that allows us to just identify
the fact that this is you we get your
site key that's attached to your token
so what we can certify that this is
indeed coming from your application so
you know when we have bad requests and
you know broken tokens Etc that are
usually attackers trying to pretend that
they're you we can reject those
assessments and you have what we call
expected actions this is a very
important piece of the puzzle because
when you specify that for example this
is a login page a sign up page that
allows these the action specific models
to trigger meaning that recaptcha when
they see that it's a login page and you
actually specify it will be able to make
sure that you receive you know the login
protection models as opposed to the
generic models robot management
now the good thing also is that you get
a risk score so here what happened is if
this was a real user trying to log in on
your page
you'll get this score and you'd be able
to say you know what this is actually a
genuine user this is not a bot I'm going
to let them through now we can look at a
different use case with account Defender
for that same user trying to log in
so as we said earlier
um you know account Defender was really
part of the shift in the way we're
approaching things because it allows us
to really track over time how the user
is behaving
how are they behaving on your login page
and whether or not this user should be
letting should be letting into your
application
and so here in this example what you
provide us on top of in your request is
what we call the hashtag count ID so the
concept of hashtag account ID is really
a
hashed version of the constant that you
use to track the user on your
application we do this just because we
actually don't need to know that it's a
Gmail account a Yahoo account all we
want to know is that this is the same
user coming back so we ask for that
constant so we can track over time how
do they behave what network are they
using what device are they using in
order to login into your page so we can
compute that risk score over time
we're also like gonna introduce a way
for you to send us plain text email
addresses for example or usernames if
you want but this FYI this is a way for
you to do it in a privacy preserving
manner
and then again the same request goes out
and here you get what we were discussing
earlier you get your risk analysis where
you get a score between zero and one but
here now you have an account Defender
assessment that will tell you this is a
profile match so this is indeed butter
coming back and that you could actually
if you want skip to FX we have high
enough confidence that this is good
this is very powerful because
here if it was an attack perpetrated by
a human or click Farm
here we capture tells you as well that
this is actually better coming back so
you should be pretty fine
but let's look at an example where there
is unusual activity
um in this case one of the developers
says that I'm in the South Pole and so
again you passes that hasht account ID
so let's assume that this is better
trying to log in later on
what you get is well this isn't indeed a
human as expected however this is
suspicious login activity going on
meaning that account Defenders models
have detected that there is a deviation
in the way they log in therefore you
should actually request a two-factor
authentication for this user because
they're at risk of account hijacking the
awesome thing about this is as you saw
this whole life so it's under 50
milliseconds it's an API response so you
can ingest the attacker has no clue
about what you know so you can actually
gamify this as much as you want you
could tell them look this user doesn't
exist in my database you could give them
a 400 error you can give them you know
whatever error you want you can redirect
them to a fake shop you can do honeypots
really here it's up to you on like how
you want to build your response to the
attacker
so really account Defender is a powerful
tool that you can add to your toolkit so
that now you're not just focusing on the
Bots which is a vector to an attack but
on the actual nature of the attack and
the question that everybody's trying to
answer which is is this account at risk
of being hijacked
for account creation it's very similar
so if I'm a fraudster one two three here
in this case they don't have yet a
hashed account ID because they haven't
created the account but what we
recommend our customers to do is to
actually generate one on the Fly keep it
so that they can earmark the account for
later and that that was important for
the next point that I'm gonna show you
so again here you get a 0.8 so
highlighting is for it to be a human
however these humans trying to probably
create a fake account because of the
behavior we've seen and the behavior
behavioral signals we collect so in this
case you have a few choices if you're
really convinced that this is a fake
account you could block it if you have a
doubt and you don't want to lose those
marketing dollars you spent on this
person you can actually block Advanced
functionalities on your platform say for
example your streaming platform you
don't want to let them you know do live
streaming for example until they send
you an ID Etc you can use this data in
order to you know enforce that step up
off
and the reason why actually that hashtag
account ID becomes so important is
because you can then use the
investigation API and that's the related
accounts API I was talking about earlier
where you can actually scale for a
specific user like say a bad user for
example if you want to check their ID
what we're going to do is actually we're
going to return you
um the cluster token and that cluster
token will allow you to actually go in
through this group
and for that ID that we saw
it will allow you to actually see all of
the other accounts that are related to
it that we think are the same owner so
for example in this case there are I've
had the customers we were talking
through yesterday we had a cluster of 12
000 accounts
I don't know about you but I don't own
12 000 accounts on any platform
and you know in some cases you may have
legitimate cases for example at home you
may have a case where I may have five
accounts in my same house that are using
spotify or Netflix
but in this case if I have 150 accounts
something is catchy so a lot of this is
actually available to you so that you
can pass it on to your manual reviewers
to approve transactions you can pass it
on to your data science team so that
they can investigate Etc
so really powerful tool last one that I
wanted to demonstrate real before we go
to the Q a is fraud protection fraud
protection in this case is really cool
because the basic really implementation
of it is when the user clicks on
checkout
you'll be able to pass us a little bit
more information in this case it's you
know
what payment method are they using the
card bin which is the first six the last
four the value the and the USD for
example the currencies USD that allows
us to build those models to understand
do attackers on this website just check
out ten dollar items because it's easier
to bypass and maybe they've checked out
a thousand of them or maybe in this case
you know it's a three thousand dollar
item so it's high value so maybe we want
to make sure we check that what you get
then is is the subbot or human I'm still
a human so it's good to hear
um and in this case what you get is this
scores that we saw earlier so here the
scores are between zero and one again
one being risky zero being low risk and
in this case you know there is a low
risk of the instrument being stolen the
transaction risk is very low your risk
score for car testing is at zero and
actually because we know that this
person with this profile in other parts
of our network has not had a bad
behavior we give you a high confidence
score that this person is trustworthy so
you can actually approve their
transaction instead of maybe rejecting
it so this is very cool but let's look
at actually the advanced implementation
of this for a bad user
foreign
so in this case we have an advanced
version where you can give us a lot more
information right so what you do here in
your request is pass us things like
again everything around the instrument
being used the address being used the
user right so for example like we verify
this email in the past or not the phone
number the merchant data the items
they're trying to take out right so for
example in this case a demo item but
this could be a PlayStation 5 sneakers
you name it or for example you know a
donation and then some information
around the Gateway and what you get by
giving us that more that additional data
is actually more robust scores in this
case what we see is that the stolen
instrument verdict is is really high 70
chance that this is a stolen instrument
being used to check out
transaction risk is actually a hundred
percent the car testing risk is at 100
so there is a high likeliness that a
human is trying cards on your page in
order to receive they can check out with
that with that card and we really don't
trust this user there's a 10 you know
trust score therefore you should be
fairly comfortable you know declining
this um this transaction so really
powerful tool which again in under 50
milliseconds pre-auth which is very
important I think that's a key aspect is
this doesn't go to your payment
processor which means if this is if this
would have resulted in a chargebacks you
don't have to pay that dispute fee it's
twenty dollars on average you don't have
to wait those three months lead time for
them to come back and you don't have to
pay the transaction fee that you pay to
repayment processor which leads to even
more losses and if you are a retailer
you're not actually losing the goods
that you've shipped through this
attacker so really powerful tool again
pre us
under 15 milliseconds and you get those
responses so that you can use them with
the rest of your
um workflows we've seen customers use
this for example with things like manual
reviewers
all right this is the end of the demo
and I believe the end of the
presentation
[Music]
foreign